the royals start tonight with a record
of 10 and 15 six and a half games back
of first place minnesota win meritfield
will leave things up and he is having a
terrific month of august hitting 302
overall
and there goes merrifield into left
center field that's a base hit he's off
for second to throw by cave is going to
be late it's a lead-off double for win
six double on the season for win man
i'll tell you that's a great way to
start it right there just like that now
he does have good numbers off otorizzi
anyway but look this is nice way to
start so first and third nobody out
he takes a crack pops it up
shallow right field oh and the ball
drops lopez races to second
they got confused sano and vargas they
weren't sure who was going to make the
play and this is an outstanding
defensive team they've only suffered
four errors prior to tonight
well that's second baseman's ball all
the way if he can get to it
so lair the batter first and second
that ball is smacked deep to left that's
a way back and gone
home run jorge solaire oh he absolutely
tattooed that ball
just get it in the air solaire 108 exit
below he knows what to do good to see
you back jorge
oh way to clean up the bags that's
exactly what you want out of your number
four hitter that's why they call them
the cleanup man clean up the bases that
was a little spinner that just spun
there and you could tell by the body
language of odorizzi
that he's really unsure tonight
we'll bring up the birthday boy a-ray
adrianza turning 31 today
dribbled up the line
and a run will score
and adrian's retired
it's
rosario coming in from third
in there strike three call
fastball is just catch the bottom of the
zone right there and
jeffers you got to go you don't hack
i'll send you back
how about that
change up strikeout number four for
danny duffy oh yeah he was in gonzalez's
mind that time here it is the equalizer
to a right-handed bat and that's a
change-up down out of the zone
not good for the hitter
perfectly located cam wants this one on
the ground here wasted
he does and it's a beautiful chain jump
late fade duffy with the strikeout three
strikeouts at the inning
that hit oh to rizzy
and they'll be runners at first and
second
and where did it get him
i hope he's not holding his right arm
because that
because of that where the point of
impact was
right above the elbow it appeared
maybe it didn't get the arm but got the
rib cage instead
right in the right below the right pec
and he went down that's
tough to get your win back
and order izzy looks like he's going to
come off here so on comes
jorge alcala
walked him and the royals score a run on
a bases loaded walk by whit merrifield
shocked the house the royals not known
for their for their walking and we
actually walked where the bases loaded
got a run way to go wit
wow there you go let's just throw three
fastballs and see if we can get this guy
got him got him with that slider he
chased ball four nice job there alkaline
pitching out of a big jam they only get
one run
here is rosario the twins need to start
banging the ball around here
dozier racing over and lunges and makes
a fine catch
man that was almost a tweener in between
them it's kind of close you know
merrifield that could he yell dozier's
yelling he's calling for it but
merrifield has priority
so dozier i think
merrifield heard dozier calling before
merrifield did and so
mayorfield's gonna let
dozier go ahead and show his athleticism
uber says thanks
and a breaking ball gets a swing and a
miss and strikeout number five
number six
since
the bases loaded walk to marathi
it's seven up seven down with six
strikeouts
the only guy that put the ball at play
was franco who hit the pop-up to end the
inning
weekly hit
gonzalez fires they still got him way to
stay with it marwin gonzalez juggled it
but made the play it's a three up three
down six for alkala
dozier will bat with lopez at first
and that ball is a goner for hunter
dozier
and the royals have a 7-1 lead
hey you know what that's a beautiful
stroke by dozier and now with him
climbing up and getting getting some at
bats now coming into this game he just
had 28 at bats i mean he's starting to
get his timing down and it was a no
doubter that's a good fastball easy
swing
look at the head position there he gets
his power from his lower half
that's a beauty
one to adrianza
and that one gets away
and coming in is cruz so no to third
base so the twins get at least
one in
a wild pitch
royals trying to close out the twins as
minnesota comes to bat got barlow in the
game
and that ball stroked up the middle but
caught by monday
game over the royals win their 11th
victory this year